foreign
already
although granted we could have done many
more episodes if we just streamed every
Friday but you know how life gets well
it gets in the way especially during the
during Christmas season during the
holidays yeah
for sure
all right
that and the fact that I've been sick
for a week or
we have to do a gear check
item check yeah let's compare items
yeah oh yeah there we go okay
gear check gear tracking progress
one zero one three one oh where where
yeah when you have a spirit Temple P for
some reason
we are the same right no we were the
spirit Temple pee that but we haven't
been to the spirit Temple yet right
I don't think so
you have a map of jabu jabu yeah well to
be fair the maps where the maps have
actually been more useful than other
than that I think we're on equal oh no
wait you have a
brother uh I have a present about key
you have a breath of the wild key I uh I
don't have that one
yeah like I said you have a spirit on
pupita I wish it didn't show if it was
Master Quest or normal
hello I think you can
I'm not sure if you can disable it I
think maybe if you there's an option
where I think if you find a map then it
tells you what it is
um
okay
Jesse is my brother yeah
Okay so
uh I guess I found that key here
how much of the water tempo have I
explored so far actually
that's a good question most of it it
seems
[Music]
um
have we been to the spirit Temple at all
yeah I know the Decker tree is the
spirit Temple I
um
yeah that's true yeah you're right I'm
just gonna go today I know that we've
been to the spirit Temple though before
um don't remember anything else I just
remembered that we've been there
done it's so hot in here
uh
oh yeah
oh no wrong
okay so I completed half of divorce
Temple apparently
that means that there's still stuff to
find
we have the Prelude of light
I hope we do nope
no we don't
uh at least I I do not that means we
have to walk
we have to walk it all the way to the
Temple of time every time
we also don't remember anything Stuart
so uh we are in the same boat as you uh
it's been like a month I think at least
yeah something like that
uh
that means I have to walk all the way to
the Deku Tree
I I guess I could take the shortcut to
the forest well I have one force temple
key which means I can advance exactly
one door
I hope it's the last one
I hope we saved last time I'm pretty
sure I did yeah I hope I did I know at
one point the fact that we are pretty
much equal in terms of keys it's just
that you have a bottom of a breath and
wild key yeah
I remember at one point I forgot to save
while I was here and then I opened my
laptop like three days later and it was
still running the whole time so so I
made sure to save it right away
what
oh shut up
shut up Navi
shut up Nabi oh oh oh help me do we have
the bow yeah
we have like a lot of items most of them
actually is there anything
click around shot I'm gonna grab some
food
nope nothing interesting
[Music]
we'll go
time
give me some juice no that's not juice
I need some magic juice
well here's the door that I never went
through
let me guess there's another unlocked
door over there
yep
well that was pointless
there was no there's no reason to come
in here
nope yeah
I just wasted
a gigantic amount of time
oh shut
up shut up
oh hey Romana
yeah long time no see
the holidays kind of got in the way
best wishes to you too
I hope you had a great New Year's
celebration actually what did you do on
New Year's Eve I was sick unfortunately
I should pay attention to what I'm doing
I got sick the uh today the day after
Christmas
so you didn't do anything no I was you
were you were more or less too well I
was more or less too sick to get out of
the bed so which is mostly just stayed
in bed
yeah I was planning to visit mom and dad
but you know I don't want to make them
sick so I just kind of stayed at home
okay
[Music]
hi Daniel
it wasn't covet though thankfully this
time good of you to join us
nah you've already had it right yeah
back in May uh like last year although
all those variants
I I don't I don't know anymore I got
pretty sick to be honest covered
I mean not life-threatening to be sick
but like the sickest I felt in like the
past maybe five years or so oh thank you
for that Kieran Karen Buckley thank you
yeah happy tears of the Kingdom year
we were actually talking about our our
best uh I expect uh what we expect her
not necessarily our wishes our wishes
yeah our wishes for tears of the Kingdom
and it basically basically came down to
uh more dungeon stuff yeah
[Music]
foreign
problem more or less
yeah that's what it basically came down
to
well I have a bottom of the wealthy I
mean breath of the wild key so I might
as well go to breath of the Wild
yeah the whole Netherlands is sick right
now it's kind of it's kind of crazy
we had uh
I had the uh I'm not sure if it's
I'm not sure what the exact name in
English is
uh RS virus probably heard it you know
what it means screw it
like the flu mixed with a cold more or
less
it doesn't sound too bad no it wasn't as
bad as Kobe that's for sure but yeah I
still would rather not make people sick
if I can help it
it's very Noble of use uh
you know Mom and Dad are getting uh are
getting older too
wouldn't want to make them unnecessary
[Music]
it becomes a big a big guy
becomes bigger the New Year's was good
played some board games ate many only
bowling
and now I'm also sick with the rest of
Holland
oil balls oil balls
how are you going to explain this in
English
I'm sure though I'm sure there's a name
for it right it's the Dutch delicacy
though I'm not sure it is yeah I don't
think they
it's tradition in any other countries
less and less it is I'm not sure
[Music]
dungeon ideas for tears of the Kingdom
ah
not necessarily unique but I just want
to see more variety
I want to see as much variety as
possible like oh
one of the one of the things that I had
was like a completely [ __ ] black dark
dungeon that you need uh did you need to
use a oh I forgot about this did you
need a
like a torch or something to navigate
through
maybe like a horse after playing uh
Elder ring Alden ring
I kind of realized
we need that kind of variety in the
dungeon Department
because you had like uh mini dungeons in
that game
but they they had a couple of different
themes it wasn't all like like with the
Chica shrines like all the same
Aesthetics
you had caves and catacombs and
just uh just more stuff
[Music]
but yeah I'm I'm very excited for uh
tears of the Kingdom so far
and I think the fact that we don't know
much about it only adds to the mystery
so that once we do finally get a proper
uh trailer I think it's gonna be really
really something special yeah we know
next to nothing about the game so far
except that it takes place in the sky
really yeah yeah well some some of the
mechanics like with the
hand thing
where it's called yeah but we don't know
how it's going to be implemented
not really anyway true
where did that chest spawn how many gold
sculptures do you have
uh
okay you definitely didn't get the
reward yet I just realized that I cannot
go into the bottom of the world I never
got the Song of Storms oh and uh I think
we talked about this like in the last
stream that I have no idea where it is
where did that chest spawn
I'm gonna have to find one more
sculpture line and Hope I get something
good
[Music]
I think you have to put that
time block on it but I'm not sure
oh it's over there no of course we don't
[Music]
know
oh come on
do these go on for hours uh usually
about two hours or so
we we actually started we actually
started early
did we it's a hard container
yeah we've started pretty early yeah we
usually uh like two hours here
can you
hover boots work while you're carrying
something yeah they do they do yeah
let's see what the oh let's see what
this time block does
I have to walk my ash all the way to
Bruno's Fortress
nice Vince says
I hope they have a different collectible
uh other than korok seeds yep yeah yeah
we talked about that about how
once you're like 20 maybe 30 hours in
like you realize how repetitive stuff
starts to become you have a pretty clear
idea about what you're gonna find like
it's a shrine or it's a cork sweet most
of the time yeah and at some point it
starts to like once your inventory slots
like start to fill up well
once you get it once you start getting
enough inventory stuff
the peroxide is going to become
meaningless
yeah
sure does I know why they did it though
why they put in so many it's just to
make sure that everyone always finds
enough
[Music]
it's been underground cave system
s
start
underground cave system like an elder
ring
but yeah I hope there will be something
like that on the ground stuff man I hope
it's not happening I hope it's not just
stuff in the sky
oh man can you imagine if it's like uh
tears of the Kingdom you have the
Overworld and you have sky islands and
you also have a whole underground like
sections like three different
Road sections maybe more layers yeah
that would be so cool
it would fit the the the overall tone
yeah I think it's something that Zella
needs to start exploring more of mural
to be honest like in the previous 3D
titles there were caves it was just like
like a small area where you you kill a
few enemies you get a chest and you're
out
like it would be really awesome if there
were like large tunnel systems and stuff
yeah like maybe old like abandoned ruins
that's the kind of stuff that we need to
see
for sure
and there has to be something to do
there
not just like oh it's just there for
Laura or something like that and ivory
Laura's fine but uh I also want
I want to feel like I had a purpose to
come there yeah
oh it's in this place again
did we ever find the grudo trading
grounds at all
the gorilla training ground uh yeah
I think so
did I explore like nothing underground
Clorox yeah
no no more Clorox please
I don't think there's anything I can do
here
this aiming system
this aiming system is the worst
it's just one tiny
oh I'm not gonna kill it actually
I'm not gonna I don't want to spend my
my only key just yet I need to wait
until night time oh
there's something I can do here
oh and
guys
that is so unfair
[Music]
I just realize how much it sucks that I
don't have the summer storms because
they're like there's like like how many
caves are in there in this game that you
can open with the songs on there's so
many of them
this is kind of a problem
here
I'm just gonna use the
brute force method
we have the Samsung how did he not hit
me
foreign
we are doing good how about your
yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I don't have the mirror Shield so
I will not be able to advance here so
this was pointless
and killing all the enemies did not do
anything
I'm gonna see what the 40 sculpture work
is uh
currently playing all the Zelda games
leading up to tears of the kingdoms wow
that's a lot of Zelda games
that is fun though
[Music]
I also want to hold a marathon for
myself someday where I just go
I'll just uh speed through an episode of
the game just go down the timeline the
official Zelda timeline
foreign
would take the longest to complete
honestly you just went for completion
like just the dungeons kill Galen
I would imagine brefting wild right
now
you can sleep Randall out super fast
but you said completion yeah but I mean
like normal completion just oh sorry
completion
uh
I think probably Skyward Sword because
there's so much unskippable cutscene
stuff
so much dialogue now aren't they
skippable in the remake though I hope
they make them skip the modeling I I
don't remember I didn't play the Remake
so but I hope they were chest oh let it
be something good okay I'm gonna go
please let it be something good should I
go
[Music]
well we need we need a lot of those so
okay we have like none of them
but that means I won't be able to
advance here
because these are two wait no that I
remember this being do you remember how
to solve this one oh I remember we got
like stuck on this for forever when we
played it in our own time it just it
sucks I've had such a weird system this
puzzle sucks I like
I have no idea
I know it's I know we played this for
like 20 minutes and then we randomly
like we just kept playing the ocarina of
work from what I remember yeah
and I have no like the chest falls down
right there's like a chest up there and
it falls down yeah at some point but I
have no idea something like that
I still don't know for sure why am I
there's a quick button for it okay wait
do I have all the sculptures here now
no I don't
which am I missing then
it's cultural is somewhere that I'm
missing
[Music]
yeah Shield surfing uh definitely has to
come back well now nothing happens I
also hope that they find more uses for
shield surfing
like instead of it just being cool like
being a cool way to go down mountains
maybe a waypoint system like
the win from Ghost of tsushima I'm not
I'm not too I'm not really a big fan of
waypoints it just goes back here again
it's so annoying
it makes no sense
I have no idea how he uh how we did it
last time
[Music]
this is not the way to go
actually for
one thing I really liked about breath of
the wild was exactly the fact that it
didn't have a waypoint system
that was just like you can go wherever
you wonder We're not gonna tell you
where to go except maybe
a hint from an NPC once in a while I
like how like you get the paraglider and
it just says destroy Ganon yeah that's
the only objective that was the ultimate
Chad move from Nintendo
[Music]
foreign
hey orge
it is indeed eye
oh
[Music]
I'm just gonna Spin Attack the embassy
oh this looks why why is this
why can't I Target this oh I uh
I think I don't remember what it was
[Music]
there was like a puzzle with this
like with this chest in particular that
you needed to use it for something
but I don't know what it is
think I can it was a reason I like I I
remember there was a reason for this uh
for this chest
I've only played Master Quest like one
or two times it's been a very long time
I I cannot for the life of me get used
to playing the ocarina on an Xbox and a
controller
oh really
I'm so used to the
to just either using the C buttons or uh
the 3DS setup hmm
it just feels weird I mean I agree with
the
it wasn't exactly made for a sea stick
anyway
what are we supposed to do here man I'm
trying to like I don't have a
wrecking my brain around both the
purpose of this chest was
I'm not sure if it was a mirror Shield
thing or not
oh you just have to okay well that's
Master Quest for you you just beat the
[ __ ] out of it it's like randomly
shooting like the long shot at a wall
and works in the water temple okay
where is it where did it go
[Music]
I'm gonna turn in my Scotland
see what I get
[Music]
oh do we get an iron knuckle fight yes
we do
there's a big oral sword to hit or three
hit I'm not sure how many hits he takes
with the bigger with the big one yeah
you cannot Shield him anyway so might as
well use the big chorus or take like
three hits and then he's dead I think
I'm gonna shoot him in the face look
hello
I had no idea that it actually did it
did that yeah
you can
turn
oh my God it goes down so much faster
than with the child it's so easy
[Music]
I remember fighting this one as Child
Link is ready it's pretty was pretty
difficult back in the day I probably had
a few game overs as a kid
now that you know the strategies I mean
yeah obviously but like the first time I
remember killing him with bomb shoes the
first time I think
yeah but as a like that's the first time
as a kid then
he's pretty intimidating he does like
three yards of damage
this is a like all-purpose randomizer so
both Master quests and vanilla mixed
together uh you can't go back now after
this because it just spit you out of the
desert Colossus
all that for us
hmm
wait maybe yeah you're screwed too
because oh well actually maybe yeah you
can get through that I think I already
opened that before though but I'm not
sure
no I don't remember watching there
a stick oh
I'm wondering where it is I don't are
you sure we went to the group of
training ground before
um
yeah yeah I don't know
there's a boss key up there
but we don't have a beam we don't have a
weed
okay what do you have
uh it's not help that's not useful I'm
actually happy that that this this
happened oh here's the other ironical
we're gonna do another one
[Music]
come at me bro anything I can do in any
dungeon at this point
[Music]
I have like a key for it did you find
anything in the water temple at all I
don't remember it's like five weeks ago
oh well I thought you were doing a water
temperature before
I'm just gonna go I have a small key
maybe I'll find something
like even in the spirit Temple there's
still one enemy that's in no other part
of the game it's like a new introduction
like that yeah it's the uh the Anubis
right Anubis yeah
so even in the
last dungeon if you don't count ganon's
Castle
they still introduce new enemies
meanwhile in breath of the wild if you
once you learn one Province you
basically have found everything except
maybe the molduga
yeah the enemy variety definitely uh
there are no hinoxes right at the grape
on the great plateau
no I remember when we played uh but I'm
not really
I forgot this is not what I where I
wanted to go they are everywhere though
I remember it's very
easy to have encountered every enemy in
the game in like 10 to 20 hours
something like that yeah I believe it
did we ever make it to the desert plazas
before yeah we did but not as a as a kid
right no I got we didn't we have the
warp song
but you cannot no no we don't have to
warp song we don't have to warp song
nope maybe I do I remember the first
time when we played uh when we played
breath of the Wild on the release date
right
it's okay yeah together I remember when
we uh we did even type yeah but we were
also exploring the great plateau and you
came across the the gigantic Stone Talus
for the first time
remember
oh yeah you were the one who encountered
it first and you had no idea what was
going on I had no clue oh man this
um
those were the days
uh back in your old apartment oh wait
that that is the uh
how does the other song go
I think you could complete the ice cover
now at this point
I have an empty bottle I don't think we
have one
all from memory what I said I said I
think we can complete the Ice Cavern now
which yay
everyone's favorite dungeon
it I wouldn't even call it a dungeon
doesn't even have a boss yeah I mean
it's not like a wolf post yeah wow
oh stop
there's a true boss
but uh like we didn't have a bottle I
think the first time we went in here
yeah we didn't live and we didn't link
with a beard would be pretty cool yeah
speaking of Link having a beard I
there's something that I have to know
what why does link have an earring in
this game when he's an adult when he was
Frozen in time or raru gave it to him
yeah why like link was trapped in the
sacred realm for seven years and he was
like you know what it would look good
with some earrings
he made special earring uh earrings for
him I mean
I'm gonna have to wait there at your
side for seven years
got to do something to kill time
oh yeah I remember you can just keep
killing it I can go in there you're
indicate you're in there like a Song of
Storms
I really hope I come across the Song of
Storms just by
beating the crap out of it
stop like he's already dead
they need to make a parody of this Blake
just hammering the ground just a skull
going up and down
that's poor scale till I got rattled
rattled into Oblivion
oh this does this mean I have to keep
walking back and forth because I only
have one bottle
oh I know
I will go to the Ice Cavern too then
oh there's a few chests have you ever
been to the fire temple yeah oh yeah of
course because we have the fire tank I
had tuna
and we also have key you do yeah
I found a spirit temple key in here if
that helps you in any way
I mean we don't have the mirror Shield
so I'm not sure
yeah I'll helpful it's gonna be here
that is a problem do I have the summer
storms yeah you do and I'm very very
envious of the fact that you do oh yeah
I do but but I don't I don't remember
being inside the bottom of the well
though you do you have been there I have
yeah I'm sure of it but it didn't do
anything
I don't know there was nothing I know
that you've been there that's all that's
all I remember I'm trying to figure out
where the Song of Storms could have been
because I am missing out on so many
caves that you can
get to with the
I feel like a Zelda movie would be a lot
like Lord of the Rings I don't know a
Lord of the Rings is more about
companionship and traveling with a well
a fellowship right like uh whereas
Link's Adventures are usually pretty
lonely yeah it's like the world is has
been taken over and I mean I mean while
uh link is like crawling through yeah
and Lord of the Rings it's like dark
dungeons in Lord of the Rings it's uh
you can like you you have my sword you
have my hammer you have my bow
right wasn't that the quote Yeah you
have my action
or and my ax
I need to rewatch it again someday I'm
thinking if there are any movies that
are very close to what Zelda would have
been
I guess Indiana Jones to an extent
although I don't remember link fighting
Nazis
I hate this room but this this honestly
this might be my least favorite room in
the game
like
in all of Ocarina of Time I'm pretty
sure this is my least favorite room
that's not that bad
sucks that sucks if you know the
solution
it just takes so long and there's like
my least favorite enemy in the game is
in here like in abundance
like if your least favorite any in the
game in the game isn't the The Ice Keys
then there's something wrong with you
yeah
ice skis are the worst
it's just like oh you got hit well how
about you just stop using the controller
for like five seconds
yeah and the aiming system in this Set
uh game is not actually I should stop
watching your screen because I I keep
running into walls because
there's nothing interesting going on on
my screen except me failing
all right I will watch then
okay that was pretty cool
I still cannot believe that this is the
year that we're gonna get a new Zelda
game man
it's always such a
and then uh coach is such a big big
thing you know it's like an event and
then coaching on screen and it's like so
we know if you've been looking forward
to it but Koji condo uh what was the guy
yeah oh yeah sorry I I mixed it I mixed
them up
the former composer yeah he's the
composer no that's that's more of a
composer comes on streets yeah shut up
to tell people that Japanese names they
all sound the same to me I'm sorry
that's uh not very nice
oh you're not very nice
thank you
yeah what if he just comes on I'm
screaming like yeah we know you've been
looking forward to it but
actually we're delaying it for another
eight years because we uh we were almost
we were almost done but then we realized
it's not good enough and then we
realized that we wanted to do everything
else like everything differently
just do it the uh Metroid Prime four way
yeah
[Music]
is a good looking man for his age I feel
so bad for a Metroid fans man I mean
they did get Metroid dread though I was
about to say they got dread
it's not the same though
well I mean Prime for
it it just wasn't good enough
wait why is he in the middle
until we give him the letter which we
don't have but then how did you get to
the Ice Cavern because it's the dungeon
entrances are mixed up
including the the yes where is the Ice
Cavern I don't I actually don't remember
where where I came from uh oh my God I
walked all this way for nothing where
did I where did I come in again
uh maybe someone in chat remembers
I don't think Prime 4 is canceled I just
think they're doing a whole like
because you have to remember they
basically started production already and
then they just were just like ah this is
not good enough
we're going to switch to a different
studio and we're gonna start from
scratch
I think it was a very honest thing to do
actually to just be like nope this is
not up to our standard they could have
easily released it
if they really wanted uh really wanted
to
I'm just yeah they were just like nope
like I've been burned out by
like incomplete games and like games
that were that had like uh half of the
stuff they wanted to put in like cup
because of playing old things well
that's why I have no
single gripe with the fact that they
took so long with the tears of the
Kingdom some people are very frustrated
about the development cycle of Tears the
kingdom and I I cannot for the life of
me understand why I mean we saw what
happened with Wind Waker I mean yeah
it's quite long it's it's a long way but
that's nothing new for us all the game
yeah it's one year more than average but
we also had covet so yeah but I mean we
saw what happened it just means it's
gonna be a big big freaking game
there's gonna be a lot to it yeah but
like we remember what happened with Wind
Waker too where like it was there were
like like a bunch of stuff
there was a bunch of stuff the stuff
that was cut from the game that they
they like planted like at least three
dungeons like two or three dungeons yeah
I'd rather just like have a complete
experience
instead of a padded out experience
so I'm I'm fine as long as Chris Pratt
voices Link in the next game I'm fine
laughs
foreign
which do you remember which dungeon is
there
four stamp lanterns uh despair Temple no
yeah no yeah that's the Deku Tree
oh yeah you're true uh that's true I
have no idea then I'm gonna check
we've made progress we found some keys
what am I doing wrong
you know what screw it I'm just going to
push it here didn't I already do this
oh we don't have saria's song right
no apparently
no
we still cannot get rid of this bastard
I mean you can can you like no there's
no
definitely I'm pretty sure I've been to
the floor sample though as an adult oh
you gotta be
wow
I'm not gonna swear like do we have I
really want to maybe we have the song
yeah we do have the song
now I have to remember from I'm not
gonna look it up let's see how does it
go again the minuet the menu
[Music]
that's how it goes
[Music]
ha
do
[Music]
oh I have to do it all over again why
wait a day I was no there was absolutely
no reason for that would you watch a
Zelda anime I'm not a not the biggest
anime fan but I would watch that you're
not the biggest anime fan since the
person who's like what no that's I'm
reading someone's oh
you've watched the top of anime not a
ton or way more than me at least
now I I don't think
yeah well the uh all that much the
whatever the studio is Studio Ghibli
stuff though
did we beat a lot of the the dong Goose
Cavern why do you guys have to respond
why there's still one chest here
[Music]
foreign
at least I did maybe that's the key that
maybe it's the key to everything
somewhere on the second floor that way I
can just take the shortcut
s
almost burned my feet
all right
I remember I think I think we are due
for a new Mario
title for sure either 2D or 3D
I mean it's been a while since yeah
that was not really like a full
yeah but I was gonna say like yeah we
did get Bowser's Fury at least
which I heard was a good time
it was I'm not sure I haven't played it
but I heard it was a good time I had fun
with it
no I I thought it was uh I thought it
was fun
did you play it with someone with
someone else
uh I played a little bit with uh Carol
but at some point I
took over
we just got a compass I think oh what's
that for the water temple
wait huh wait what oh that's a pona song
I thought you got zarya sound
not that it matters because you don't
really need it
okay not really well you can play uh
for the for for darunia
there's like nothing I can do with the
opponent I mean I can get opponent but
why why do I need a prona I don't know
uh I guess we've already done all this
I'll check the boss room just to be sure
but I'm pretty sure we have already
beaten this one does he Pawn unlock
anything my favorite 3D Mario
uh This is Gonna sound very weird to
most people but Sunshine is my favorite
[Music]
3D Mario game it's a tough one
I just have the best memories I I I
recognize that it's definitely not the
best 3D Mario from a technical
standpoint
by any means but I just have the Fondest
Memories
played Odyssey I mean 64 64 and sunshine
were the ones I grew up with I have to I
should play Odyssey uh you haven't
played Odyssey no I still haven't played
him
like put the controller down and go pick
it up
I will I will you said I could borrow
your coffee so I don't know why I mean
you can yeah
it's uh
I think I put like uh maybe next time uh
next stream you can bring it to work and
yeah it's a good game I put like a good
maybe 45 50 hours in it or something I
do have to say the first uh Galaxy was
also oh yeah I love Mario yeah I
remember that's so good I remember we
played it together and uh when it first
came out yeah but for some reason I
don't have the same crazy memories that
I have I don't know
something about Mario Sunshine it was
summer when it came out here I think
yeah
I think it was just it was just such a
fun game I'm pretty sure Sunshine is the
one that I played the most out of all uh
3D Mario games where they're like the
most amount of I think it's also the
game that I completed the most amount of
times yeah well the Mario game that I
completed the most amount of time
and of course 64 I also have great
memories of but I was so young me too
I mean I had your copy so I played that
a lot too
controversial opinion Mario Odyssey is
just okay nothing amazing I mean to each
their own
right I think it's well I think it has a
lot of missed potential but
like I think it's a good game like what
wait what where was the uh ice cover
oh yeah with uh I want to at least Beat
It
well there was nothing really useful in
there well actually yeah well there was
there was a key that you need
trying to think where I just came from
wait where was it
oh yeah no it was the water temple the
water temple is the Ice Cavern yeah okay
all righty then I wish we had the
Samsung
ah thanks Legend Zoom
did we make it
we actually have to unlock Epona or do I
already have her
[Music]
foreign
give me all your money even though I
cannot carry
nope I need to unlock her first
I really hope we don't need to do the
the bow hunting thing
Let's uh thing black links it's it's so
personal
like
I know full well that Mario Sunshine is
not the best Mario game just from a it
had quite a wonky camera system it was
probably the most frustrating out of all
of the 3D Marios that's for sure it also
didn't have that many levels compared to
many other Mario titles
yeah it's just a setting it uh it's my
own little Adventure I had back in the
day and it just it stuck with me
that and we've both always been summer
like summer people yeah they don't like
winter that too yeah
for sure
what a temple interest do we have a song
to that
yeah
I don't have to walk
[Music]
yeah that's easier said than done Legend
Zone I don't know where the bigger
wallet is
I don't even have I don't even have the
biggest wallet yet since it is all
randomized
we did shoot the sun right yeah I I
remember getting nothing and being
pissed off but you also have the biggest
wallet and I don't have it and I have no
idea where you got it there's a bigger
one right
oh you have the biggest oh this is
Ocarina of Time there are no bigger ones
I still up to 200 one
I mean I don't really need the 500 one
though I mean we don't you don't really
need rupees for anything at this point
not really no
I do think the music to the Ice Cavern
is really well done
it actually feels I think it's really
boring but that's just me
well it's not like a track I would
listen to to be like yeah but like the
It sets the
feels like
cold when you hear the song
it communicates the idea
frozen-ness I mean yeah I guess
I don't know how to explain it
have a bottle yeah we do they even have
a fish in it
[Music]
I remember you can block him I think
yeah you can just block him and he
doesn't know what to do anything you can
do that on the second round too when
he's much faster
how much faster is he on the second
round I've never really considerably
faster actually okay fast enough that I
can see people failing at it
probably myself included I think I've
failed it
but I'm giving myself a break because
the controls are not the best I have
like four tries so even if I fail
whatever controls are a little bit stiff
you just have to cut them off in the
corner and then like try to stay ahead
of them
you know you block him and then he
doesn't know what to do
he's like
stupid kid
oh Mike
you're gonna eat an arrow
arrow to the face
see if I can no scope him yeah
[Music]
I hear another one
I'll never met you or leave this Ranch
people told me you can jump over these
Gates but I've never managed to do it
that's how I did it the first time I
played it I always jumped over the like
the big ones here I I'm pretty sure I
tried jumping over there try it try it I
know I tried it like many times and I
never you can absolutely do it this
always happens to me like you have to do
a circle around them
I just pissed off a cocoa you have to do
a full circle and then just build up as
much speed as possible
okay
I'll take your word for it
like I said that's how I didn't even
know there was a different way to do it
I believe you
but I've also been mistaken about
childhood memories well I want to play a
death stranding sometime
isn't that the game that everyone used
to call walking simulator
yeah the the not intelligent people
don't appreciate something new I I don't
know I tried I was going like crazy I
think you're just mistaken just kidding
but uh I mean
it's one of those who either hate it or
you love it type of games and I think
that's good that means it's successful
it did something new I've never played
it instead of just playing it safe doing
a horizon zero Dawn and just doing
everything by the book
now I probably pissed off Horizon zero
Dawn fans God damn it
I can never please anyone no no what are
you doing
the Epona does
but that stranding is definitely not a
walking simulator I was just kidding
about that there's much more to it well
there are people who generally think
that way and I just heard it on the
internet a bunch I'm not judging anyone
who enjoys this game I've never played
it I don't know anything if you look at
the reviews most people who are like
posted the review did not play it you
can just tell from the waiters
speak that they did not know or did not
play oh yeah there is a thing I can do
with your phone now that I remember
there's like the oh the the horse
shooting game I mean through those
portraits and when it sucks
not as much as the big pose but
still I'm not gonna give forbidden West
a try
to be honest I
[Music]
I don't know I bought the Horizon zero
Dawn I never played it I did and it was
very forgettable for me oh well
I heard good things about it when it's
like it's a quality game but it's just I
don't know maybe it was just after
breath the wild Redemption 2 and I think
I also picked up Skyrim for the first
time around that same era I just know
that uh I don't know maybe it was just
that or
it just it was just so forgettable the
only thing I noticed that it came out at
the same time is breath them out more or
less
and then it kind of uh worth of wild
kind of completely overshadowed The
Horizon zero Dawn and now we've got over
here shadowed by Elder ring yeah history
repeats I mean this year's game awards
was uh like it's different competition
man it was it was
it's not Horizons we're not winning I'm
just glad that Xenoblade 3 got nominated
at all
the three was just there for uh
getting their name out yeah
which is fine
[Music]
now I need rupees because I remember
this it's a crime that they didn't give
Xenoblade really uh best OST yeah
everyone in on the internet agrees and
it's like yeah like you said even God of
War fans yeah I agree I've seen the
comments on like uh the osts
the God of War fans if they even say
like now then I mean
God of War has good music but this one
should have gone to Xenoblade 3.
any interest in The Last of Us HBO oh
yes
for sure
I definitely do
I don't care what anyone says some
people are complaining that the actors
don't really look like the
uh the the video game characters and I'm
like well
I think it's much more important that
they act well then oh well them being
like Oh the lighter I guess we did need
to uh get any phone everyone to beat the
game
why what did you get
light and Rose oh for the archery game
yeah
uh you better remember that I hate that
game yeah me too with these aiming
controls the the thousand one is pretty
okay but this one is gonna suck
1500
I'm gonna fill out this like so many
times
like it's a weird Obsession that people
have sometimes where they're like they
really think it's more important that
the actors look exactly like the
characters in the uh in the game
[Music]
should be one of the Lesser important
things just hire good actors
who can portray it well yeah
can I at least get my money back if I
get like a thousand doesn't mean it's
gonna they're gonna kill it but from
what I've seen from the trailer so far
it looks really good
I'm very excited for it and The Last of
Us is one of my favorite video game
stories
well that sucks one of the best told
video game stories
I'm no scoping everyone
oh
beautiful
uh let me think How does it go again
I remember the combination
[Music]
I haven't played part two so I don't
know about that one
it's not because I think it looks bad or
anything I know there's been a lot of
controversy regarding the story of Last
of Us Part Two
but that's not the reason I've never
played it it's just uh I never got
around to it
I might give it a shot but I I have been
spoiled to death so I know I know
exactly what's gonna happen who gonna
die
and he doesn't
so I'm not too sure if I still want to
play it at this stage although of course
the gameplay is also important
oh my a button once I press it down too
hard it stays pressed down sticks it
sticks these aiming controls are garbage
garbage garbage
foreign
I know it might not look difficult to
the people watching but maybe these
aiming controls
these parts they are shooting are so
weird to me they're like they're like
just stretched versions of the normal
pots they just stretched them up here
yeah
it's funny uh
I think I can still make this I can I
can cheat this you actually have to do a
different
uh
combination but I'm pretty sure you can
just
this is not how you're supposed to do it
I seriously wonder how I did this as a
kid
these aiming controls a lot of patience
oh come on I know it's possible
it's probably faster to just do it in
the regular way the conventional way
oh come on
yeah it does work but I I've definitely
done it before
I think you can just maybe use the hover
boots
yeah oh my God
like one tiny flick of the control stick
and your thing just goes all over the
place
boom
[Music]
well
remember when I said I eat that you
don't need any rupees anymore at this
point
I did not remember you saying that but
that's what I said and apparently I lied
for the game yeah to keep trying over
and over and over yeah
at least I had a surplus of rupees
before I came in
foreign
and I know for sure you can also make it
here
is there a master quest version of it of
this dungeon too
Cavern the what do you remember if
there's like a master quest version of
the ice yeah there is yeah
this is not it though
[Music]
I haven't played Master Quest in a while
but like the real master quest me
neither
I'm sure we've
encountered it once in our many many
randomizers we should after this we
should do a 2d Zelda game yeah like the
the first solo right first Cellar one of
those yeah
maybe the first element it takes less
long and it's also uh just fun
I like playing the first Zelda
put an Avant Perry
hello
I hate these falling thingies icicles
all that for a freaking piece of art
well that wasn't worth it at all so I
don't have to do any of it I mean you
have to get the thousand one but that
one's easy
it's the 1500 one that sucks what was uh
oh yeah the light arrows yeah
what was that Garuda woman doing with
legendary light arrows I mean she is
like
um I don't know actually
she's the chosen one secretly I mean
she's a Gerudo though so I don't know
I mean there are thieves so she probably
stole it from somewhere
from Zelda I guess
yeah she has it normally
I'm not sure why I decided to leave
without Epona oppona so much faster but
I did
good job
how is everyone doing well we are doing
fine Jesse it's Jesse's birthday well
technically a few days ago but yeah
[Music]
I wish I had the boomerang you learned a
pona song
Sheik doesn't even show up yeah like the
camera like pants yeah it's just like
nope it just pretends like nobody's here
they just yeed a cheek out of here
happy afterwards birthday from
blacklinks oh thank you uh to everyone
who wished me a happy birthday
should I unfreeze King Zora just let
them just leave them Frozen let them rot
yeah I mean you can't that's the whole
thing about being frozen it's the fact
that you cannot rub in like but he does
but he does give you uh the the Zora
tunic normally right
yeah but it's like he just has to get
out of the way that's the only thing if
he gives you the Zora tunic that means
he will give you something else now
because it's randomized true true I wish
uh I wish I got any song other than any
Polo song to be honest
I would have preferred sorry a song
[Music]
it does lead to something
yeah but like it's not useful for
anything you can warp with it like it's
not the uh
oh yeah blind is a great boss in A Link
to the Past
oh yeah the the the team's Hideout yeah
right yeah I remember
all right well no actually I'm not gonna
spoil it I'm not sure if anyone hasn't
played Link to the Past yet oh it's a
pretty cool one going the wrong way it's
a pretty cool twist
yeah it's funny
also Link to the Past is just a great
great freaking game
I remember that I played it like for the
first time when I was like 17 or 16
because you told me to basically I
played it in between like after Majora's
Mask while waiting for uh Wind Waker
I remember waiting for the Wind Waker
also felt like an eternity
especially because the internet was
still kind of in its infancy back then
so yeah I mean looking up footage was
with a dial-up modem was not great I've
seen the Wind Waker like the space World
trailers but it's pretty bad
no but after that they started showing
like footage of the actual game
yeah but it was like a news websites uh
they started showing but in order to
buffer those videos you had to literally
wait for an hour or something but
weren't those disposables though no they
showed gameplay during that I'm just I'm
talking about like way after the space
uh World stuff like 2002 just in during
the wait they also released new footage
yeah that's true it's not like the space
World footage was the only thing we got
yeah that's the first thing though
what am I doing is this thing that
caused the the whole controversy about
the graphics the first trailer
I mean technically it was the first
trailer you cannot dive down right
technically it wasn't the first one it
was the first Target was the one uh put
again in the north fight
well but that was not Wind Waker no but
that was just it was a cool demo that
was just like the uh Wii U Tech demo
has no actual implication that it's not
really a game yeah it's true it's pretty
cool though it's just look at what our
new hardware can do
[Music]
no if he gives me a blue rupee I'm gonna
blow him up with a bomb
I'm saving his life
oh right I completely forgot that we
cannot follow Sora uh King Zora why did
you've been talking about it the whole
time yeah and I was like oh wait I
forgot to bring
[Music]
you said let him rot oh man I totally I
didn't even realize that were you out of
autopiloting or something no but I was
uh suffering through the the shooting
mini game and trying to concentrate
on the uh the shooting thing
which to be fair I mean that not the
difficult part that's the yeah A Link to
the Past would still work even today
because the
the graphics don't age
so it has timeless
Timeless graphics
uh I think it's there right here I mean
there are a lot of games that release
nowadays that still use the same
Graphics style yeah that
pixel art style
that's why I don't understand why people
want to have a remake of Minish Gap
Minish Cap still looks fantastic just
poured it over to the switch Yeah I mean
to be honest I wasn't even a fan of the
the style they use the links in the
links Awakening remake
I thought it was pretty good but like
with those games I at least can
understand because they're Game Boy
games and they they are as primitive as
it gets I still I still think it has its
charm yeah but I think what I do like I
do understand why they would remake
those so yeah if we're gonna get another
one of these types of remakes it's
definitely I I think it's probably gonna
be Oracle for ages and seasons
yeah it's more like I would I think I
would have preferred uh like a lynx
Awakening remake in the style of
miniature cap like the graphic Style
the administration I would have
preferred a uh completely new 2D Zelda
games that too with the engine of Link's
Awakening because I do like the art
style it's it's cute
it's just I don't see the ad the the
value of
remaking in Minish Cap which has such an
iconic look I don't see the point of
remaking games that are already
perfectly fine the way they are the
pixel art is so beautiful
the way it moves and uh like that's a
work of art why would you want to redo
that and to make it into something it's
not
it never was supposed to be
here did we create a spoiler log and all
did you like Link Between Worlds
I haven't played links oh you didn't
it's like the only Zelda game that I
didn't play I think it's good
well that and the the four Swords games
I didn't play those either it feels like
a bit like a half remake but it's still
it's
it still stands on its own uh the only
thing I know is that you have to like
like rent or buy your items or something
yeah it's actually uh very Innovative
for its time
innovative
as far as that they only sell the game
as far as I know that I haven't played
before
I think I played every 2D and no no blue
rupee come on
I mean I didn't really get that far in
Zola give you strength
oh you won't talk to me unless I'm like
standing on the altar
like a servant let's throw a bomb in his
face if he gives me a blue rupee I'm
actually I have to get my bombs ready
I'm gonna plant at least three
explosives all around him
oh I've come back to life
well you were not really dead but
was it you saved me don't be nervous you
you should be nervous
depending on what you're gonna give me
this is gonna decide the future of your
life
it's gonna decide your fate it looks
like you have a hard time breathing on
the water no not really
as an expression of my gratitude I grant
you this tunic
why did I have to emphasize the word
tunic
like make it red
uh they should have made it blue it's a
Bluetooth but this you won't choke on
the water
oh
I have two now two spirit Temple keys I
I think I can make it to the boss now
maybe oh no wait I don't have the mirror
Shield but yeah I mean they're still
there's chests in there well thank you
King Zora you're you're uh I will spare
your life I will spare your life
I mean we kind of needed him for
something actually we can there's
something we can do now that I just
realized
the Big Goron sword Quest I lied
huh uh we can like do the big Gorn sword
Quest thing you know
I think we need to talk to him for one
of the things
the one then he gives you like a frog I
think a frog yeah and they give you a
frog for the the girl the big girl guy
I don't know
I think you need to talk I'll I'll check
it out because I'm already in the
general vicinity
don't hurt him
thank you
I'm just trying I didn't actually hit
him it was maybe I touched his
I hurt his feet a little bit maybe I
didn't
do this yet
have you guys played tunic
I have not yet well after Alden ring I
was kind of like I I need easier games
for a little while
no souls like games anymore for at least
a year
because as much as I enjoyed Alden ring
it is hard as balls
especially for someone who has almost no
experience with the souls series or
Souls like genre
yeah I wonder when I wonder when my
first well first death is going to be in
the album ring
I mean are you supposed to no it's
deceptively hard for uh the way it looks
for for how tunic looks
it is a genuine Souls like like were you
supposed to die during the first fight
in the in the Elder ring like the first
guy you meet yeah you can you can beat
him if you're like Pro but it's uh most
most people are not gonna do it on the
on their first try well I'm not gonna
count it as my first death then no no
it's part of the place for a few hours
like I played for a few hours but I
didn't die yet so but I'm not sure how
long that's gonna last
no we're not racing we are finishing the
same seat together I didn't want to mess
with uh
online stuff or linking to the games
together we've always been playing like
this just
play the same seed and we just work
together
if he finds something he will make a
note out of it or when we eat when we
try yeah when it's not the Song of
Storms
New Game Plus is a Sweet Victory lap in
Elder ring legit beat every story oh
yeah
well to be fair I did become good at the
game in my opinion
that's around many hours
well
quite a lot
exactly
[Music]
please say hello to King Zora
I've been waiting for you with tears in
my eyes yeah you have to give him I
don't think I don't think he's gonna
no normally he would ask yeah he does
but you have the the prescription or
whatever it's called oh
yeah you have to give it to Zora and
then he gives you a frog and then you
bring the Frog to the laboratory guy and
then he gives you like an eyeball drop
thing
actually I didn't even become good at
Elden ring I just became over leveled
I was decent I was decent but I did use
mimic tear obviously which character did
you pick
for elderly
the samurai
wow you got one rupee I got one rupied
I got run I got one repeat all over me
at least it didn't say loser
that's that's the worst one where it
says that you get the pop-up a little
text box in the bottom saying loser
you're a fool that's it wait where am I
going that's not the Ah that's the water
temple did we beat the water temple yes
right yeah yeah because we have the long
show yeah yeah we did we did uh beat the
boss at least
I wonder if we got do I still have keys
for that place yeah
and the and the the
huh
you know what since we're here anyway
I'll do the spirit Temple later
I think I did
more or less ice trap you fool
s
okay
the one did do an age of the star age of
stars video yeah yeah I did
although I do have to say making content
for album ring is kind of hard because
I'm not really into the lore of Elden
ring as much as I am with the Zelda
I know Souls games have in general have
kind of a more ambiguous open to
interpretation type of lore
I don't know it just didn't work out for
me very well although I do uh want to
still do a video where I compare breath
of the wild to Elder ring
breath of the Wild versus Elder ring
well that's the thing it's not about
like seeing which game is best because
that's totally subjective
I I just want to do a video where I I
compare the two open worlds
hmm yeah no that makes more sense like
the the world itself like what they did
better in what which game because
there's definitely stuff that I think
breath of the wild did bet way better I
think the physics engine breath a lot
better
how everything interacts with the world
well that that goes without saying
because it's a different type of game
like if you gave uh the tarnished the
same Mobility as link from breath of the
wild then you could just negate L like
every challenge yeah that's true I mean
that's kind of one of the issues you're
supposed to feel limited and heavy and
weighty and not acrobatic at all yeah
that's one of the problems that well you
cannot even climb problems that breath
of wild has and it becomes kind of easy
after a while because you have so many
options at all no but it's just also the
type of game that breath of the wild is
it's just not comparable to Alden ring
there are two different genres but that
that doesn't mean you cannot uh at least
take a look at the world itself yeah
because like the map function in breath
wild is way better than the one in
eldering I hated the map in Elder ring
I don't know maybe they've updated it
since but I I remember being very
frustrated with how the way the map
works
the fact that you don't see any location
names until you hover over a Grace
thank you
I I don't know it just I didn't like it
[Music]
I'm trying to think
I still remember dropping down below
Stormville Castle yeah that was great
actually I didn't get to that place in
Stormville way like way after
we do the fishing mini game uh hey I
love watching your videos I look forward
to the next year of coverage and Theory
yeah plenty uh plenty of stuff to cover
especially uh start starting in May next
year is going to be a great time to be
as well if we if we have a if we have a
Nintendo Direct we should uh watch it
together yeah we should definitely I
want to watch that one with you
yeah yeah sounds good man you should do
that
I think it's gonna be February February
I mean it's before May at the very least
that we know well there's all like
historically there's always been a
direct in
February sometimes January but yeah I
was gonna say I think I think that only
happened once and it wasn't even a
general direct I think it's more about
they need like a beginning of the year
directed let everyone know but the rest
of the year is going to be
oh uh bergerson I think you would really
enjoy that one
I think it's uh it's your
your thing if you like exploration and
all that stuff
dungeon crawling
then you're at the uh the right place
don't expect zelda-esque dungeons like
this though it's much more classic like
the the most you will do in a in an
elder ring Dungeness
fighting enemies and pulling levers to
uh dying and dying but there's not like
walking upside down on ceilings or
raising and lowering water levels or
that's not the type of game it is
are you into jrpgs a little bit
Xenoblade
Xenoblade 3 is one of the few games I
managed to finish this year
aside from Eldon ring and the entire
metro franchise for some reason I just
wanted to play Metro
[Music]
yeah it's like a lot of jokes oh yeah
and discovering hidden past like
eldering dungeons are much more about
navigation and just surviving it's not
about puzzles per se
if you don't count navigation as a
puzzle
why doesn't it open there's some jrpgs
that I need to try someday but I just
can't really seem to find the time to uh
because they're usually longer gangs
I've already been there
I've heard a lot of good things about
the Persona series which I want to get
into at some point
huh what then I heard a lot of good
things about the Persona series which
I'd like to try out sometime I know but
I I don't know if it's my type of take
showing like if it's anything like other
jrpgs and it's probably going to take a
lot of time it's
uh that's for sure yeah
I'm also a pretty big fan of Tales of
Symphonia
although it's been a while since I last
played that game
the catacombs in Elden ring legit
freaked me out for some reason oh they
do for me too yeah
that's my jam
creepy catacombs okay what was my record
again
[Music]
do you like stylish action games uh I
don't can you give an example
of a stylish action game I like action
games
do I like turn-based combat not so much
anymore no
the Paper Mario series though right yeah
Paper Mario is a exception but like I
mean the the classic paper I tried
Bravely Default too and I was already
like uh I'm not sure I'm not so sure if
I can deal with this
it's just not my thing anymore I used to
obviously I played Pokemon back in the
day yeah me too I played a Chrono
Trigger and uh what else did I play
plenty of turn based
uh games but nowadays I don't know
sometimes you just grow out of something
doesn't mean it's bad or
actually haven't been to the basement I
just realized that the songs the songs
are only randomized amongst each other
not with the rest of the the loot
the one well the songs are all
randomized amongst each other they're
not found in treasure chests
which I for some reason thought they
were because before when we played
randomizers we always swapped the songs
in with the rest of the items yeah so I
just have to remember which
place where you can get a song you've
been to it and I haven't been to because
I need the song of storms there's no way
around it like I needed to get further
I'm trying to think where I where you
learn songs
uh
as an adult I think you can only learn
them from
Chic guru guru
even though that's technically not his
name I think he's just called music box
guy yeah or windmill guy or whatever
music box guy like how this this version
like Ocarina of Time is enju isn't
actually called anju nope but everyone
just calls her that well in the game in
the game everyone refers to her as
cuckoo lady yeah
yeah I don't think anyone did in this
game other than the they didn't really
bother with names yeah in this game in
general that which was a such an awesome
uh addition in Majora's Mask
a name and a backstory and I don't think
there are any unnamed NPCs in the in
Madrones
[Music]
not that I remember no but that's why
the side quests in Madras masks were so
much better than in this game
how do I get up there
see there's like
is that like a hook shot target have you
been to Zola
um don't remember the song you go there
right
what the heck
there's an adult you need to go did I
talk to the music box guy at all
also a big horror horror game guy but
even those I haven't played in a long
time
the only game that I always heard to
talk about was uh Silent Hill 2 Silent
Hill 2. well just Silent Hill in general
but especially too
well two happens to be my favorite but I
like all a lot of people favorite
you're definitely not like uh three and
one are not far
from two yeah I just think two had a
better story I only played one Silent
Hill game in my life
she added memories probably yeah because
it's a Wii game
I mean I watched you play home uh
homecoming like I can never think about
homecoming without thinking about
Xenoblade now at this point yeah oh
actually I think of Spider-Man when I
think of homecoming
yeah but I think I watched you play
homecoming before
yeah that one's not too too great
I don't know I only watched you play it
and uh back back in the day I always
liked watching you play stuff for some
reason
like I watched you play Bioshock Far Cry
3 I think
a bunch of stuff that I just for some
reason just like watching you play yeah
I have the same thing uh turn based
combat just grows tiresome for me too
especially with uh if it also has a
random Random Encounters
dude
[Music]
after we have not never going to forget
that
I don't think any kid who grew up in the
90s is gonna forget that I feel like it
has its nostalgic charm but I also feel
like there's a reason more and more
games are not doing it anymore you know
I mean everyone Final Fantasy also
stopped doing it now
I mean people were like
mad angry when uh super big Wario did
the uh the turn base itself again I'm
not saying that turn-based combat is
like obsolete it still has its place and
it's
it has a strategy element to it that you
cannot do with real-time combat of
course
I think I prefer real-time combat over
turn based as well
yeah like in Xenoblade yeah I like the
way Xenoblade does it yeah
even Tales of Symphonia already had
real-time comment you do get locked into
a battle arena but you do get to
actually
uh swing your sword yourself and run
around
stuff like that
ah
wow it's already 11.
yeah it's like uh like half an hour
like half an hour left please oh I can
skip this I can skip this madness
Oh
no I got I got juked
what I got duked why because I have to
play this stupid race because I went
into the raw okay
this is the wrong cave and I'm gonna
lose two because I ran into a flame I
don't really mind griding uh grinding as
long as it's not like excessive grinding
a little bit of grinding is always fun
because it is cool to over level
yourself and just kick everyone's ass
Dante broke Jesse's ankles kind of yeah
I'm not really trying my best though I
already did this I'm pretty sure yeah
twice yeah I'm just doing it because the
game forced me to
when you get it when you walk into the
wrong cave um
it's literally the only reason I'm doing
this
[Music]
can anyone miss the hidden grados from
Ocarina of Time in breath of the wild I
would love to see them return in tears
of the Kingdom
yeah or the uh those caves from Twilight
Princess those were awesome yeah there
are those were so cool they were very
long too like they were some of them
went on for like quite a quite a while
you really felt like a like a
cave Explorer
with your little Lantern walking around
I loved those caves so much
when it comes to tears of the Kingdom
videos I really don't have that much
inspiration right now to talk about like
I I have no idea how people can still
pump out
theories so quickly sometimes it's just
like another one another one another one
I'm like how how the heck do you
still have ideas to work with
like I am done I am done you're done
until we get new footage again
because the the last teaser let's be
honest it didn't reveal that much
the mural was purposely vague
did I do this
I don't remember if I did this
[Music]
well if you don't remember how am I
supposed to remember if I did then I'm
not sure why I'm doing this to myself
while I'm subjecting myself to these
games
anything from it again
yeah the lake Hayley uh Lake hylia one
I used to call it Lake Hillier before we
knew how to yeah I still mispronounce it
sometimes hillian Hylian
I mean a good old time when nobody
actually spoke so you didn't know if you
were uh if you were correct both of them
sound good though like hillion and
Hylian yeah
we know for a fact it's Hylian now but
back in the day man
nobody told you
do you remember where that royal family
tomb was nope
it's probably one of the Overworld caves
if I had to guess yeah I know it is I'm
just trying to figure out which one it
is
well there's not that many you learned
okay oh no I do uh remember it's the one
on Death Mountain Creator uh the one
inside the circle of rocks oh well I'm
not that far away I'm pretty sure that's
the one
don't I know you learned a song there
don't quote me on that though
I'm just going to places where you learn
songs until I find a place where you get
the songs oh you need wait I don't have
that no I don't
know yeah we got stuck there before
because we didn't have it inspired I
remember
we need to inspire
you know
oh I can't piss you off
wait how am I gonna get out of here now
it was here the whole time
wait what the Prelude of light was here
the whole time and we didn't even think
of it we didn't even think about pissing
this guy off
but that would mean that I did not go
into the bottom of the well no you do
you did well how you have to play the uh
The Song of Storms as a kid for him but
if you pull out your Ocarina as an adult
he's like oh that reminds me of the time
the girl the the guy pissed me off seven
years ago and he starts then he teaches
you the song yeah but you would think I
I I would have talked to him as an adult
no well I guess you didn't neither did I
I think I'm stuck for some reason I
assumed that I did there's no way back
me can just walk out I guess
yeah true
I don't think you can do that in the
next game can you
maybe you can I will check maybe I
changed it I know for a fact they
changed it in the in this if you can oh
yeah I don't think it was I didn't it
say something like your notes Echo very
far but they don't yes or something like
something blah blah blah no it's Echo
blah blah
repairs there's one place in the water
temple I haven't checked yet though I'm
just gonna I have to check it at least
one last time oh wait this is nothing
I walked to the wrong place
I'm still not used to the randomized
dungeon entrances me neither I still
have a tendency to just go to the actual
entrance the only thing I know is that
the water temple is in the fire temple
now oh
I need to go oh my God I hate this
control scheme
yeah the Ocarina was not made for the
season for the sea stick no it's so easy
to overshoot yeah
or to pick a diagonal and then it
chooses the wrong note yeah it was made
for the C buttons though so yeah
it's the same thing with the items like
The Song of Storms Guy cannot catch a
break
nope nope he has sick he has to suffer
keep playing like crazy
I
I wish we could we could complete uh but
we need to Boomerang for it it's like
the only item that we don't have
well Indians fire how do I get inside
here I don't remember how
was this the royal family tomb
what
no no no the other one inside the crater
itself I was gonna say because you need
the Song of Storms for that one
how does that gate here open
do you remember actually there was a
place here no I don't if you're asking
me about master quest water temple then
the answer is probably going to be no
there's a switch but it's behind it so
that's not gonna work
I'm pretty sure that's the only place
you can
get to
and here too
there's like immediately there's like a
gate here
damn I don't know I
I know the normal water temple pretty
well by heart but this one I also don't
remember the master quest version at all
I I only know that there's less Keys the
only thing I know is the [ __ ] where
I have to like hit the wall with your
long shot randomly and then see what
happens
I had no idea the first time
how do I open this door
this gate thingy was there actually
anything in the shop here I'm probably
just gonna be stuck inside the water
temple for that eternity no I mean until
because it's already
eleven yeah like
yeah like 12 minutes
yeah we have we've got 12 minutes left
folks 12 minutes on the clock
I'm gonna find a song of storms before
that time no matter what
Let's uh do something that needs to
happen
I'm I'm not gonna be able to sleep
tonight if I don't find the song of
storms
I need to know where it is well you have
12 minutes or else you won't be sleeping
tonight
I'm gonna be walking
I'm creating an old-school RPG at the
moment I've been working on it for two
years now wow that is a lot of
commitment and a lot of patience too
I tried making a game once and after I
built all the core assets all the core
mechanics I gave up I uh it was just too
much it was like I I had spent like four
or five months just building the
the the fundamentals to actually have
the like the the enemies the enemy AI
the
like inventory system everything
everything worked
and then I just I was just like
I still have probably like two years
left to go if I want to make this into
an actual game you know what I want to
do something else with my life yeah I
also created a a template for a game uh
it's actually based on the first seller
the very first Zelda I think I showed it
to you or at least told you about it
it's a pretty long time ago I don't I
don't remember I still think I think
mine was a mine was a 3D game and mine
was uh it was in unity I think if I
remember correctly well apparently I did
this already okay so it's not here then
how do I open this
there's no other way to get there right
I don't think so
haven't decided a name yet well that can
that will come later
nada I wish I wish I could have uh well
not finished it but I wish I could have
taken a look at it again
but unfortunately I deleted the whole
build because it was on a I needed space
on my hard drive and I was like I'm
never gonna finish this and now I regret
it so much I created I I think although
I do have to say it it runs on such an
old version of unity I don't know if I
would even be able to get it to work
again
my game ran on uh game maker I do
remember the last time checking your G
maker actually oh RPG I'm not sure which
one it is game maker are one of the two
it's been a long time
there's actually a video of it on my
YouTube channel that uh what does this
um this switch also opened up the other
Gates
check
oh no that's not what I wanted
bomb bomb
no oh my bombs you want it
roll the doors my friend like not too
long ago I had uh I wanted to I had rope
and I had oil uh lamp oil I found it in
the garage so I was like
nope but I didn't have bombs obviously
so wow so I didn't know how to make the
I wanted to post something funny to
Twitter but I was like well it's not
gonna work if I don't have bombs
and what did she come up with nothing I
didn't post anything
lump oil Rope Rope bombs
you wanted
my friend as long as you have enough
Ruby rubies oh yeah rubies
they got it wrong
blasphemy name name something they
didn't get wrong with that game well
they got Lincoln Zelda's names right
foreign
what is the land called again
isn't it yeah there's well there's two
obviously
[Music]
I don't remember the name of the other
place
isn't that something Ganon also says
like uh yeah
join me and we'll be join me link and I
will make your face the greatest
so bad it's so bad
oh well I mean it's it was the 90s can
you really blame them yes Yes actually
now that I think about it
movies were not like that yeah I mean
games were like that but even for games
it was bad Titanic came out in 89 yeah
but like voice acting in games was bad
back then but even before it was 89 98
sorry 97.
97 Jesus
oh man came out of my bridge we're gonna
die soon we're gonna die soon oh all of
us
time flies so fast it's
it's not either
20 23 here's the 20 23 Subs 20 23k Subs
yeah
maybe it wasn't the thing
what else teaches you I still have to
start working on my podcast stuff but
you know what I did an interview and it
was okay
and I'm not sure if I want to have that
as the first guest so I might just have
a talk with I don't know Nintendo black
crisis or something as the first episode
in fact I think it would be very fitting
because he was my first collaboration on
my channel ever my very first video was
a collaboration with him
he's not gonna you know what screw this
[ __ ] dungeon I hate it
I hated space I the master quest version
is just I don't know I don't get it
why is there a thing here why is this
just standing here what's the point of
it
freaking thing what is the point of this
I don't know how to open that door
I just I have no idea
so I just
yeah yeah do you even have the compass
there's no chests then who cares I think
you do have to you just need dense fire
or something yeah I mean is there
anything else besides the one chest that
we're missing
now you have the compass so I'm just
gonna get out of here
no but you should look at the map see if
there's only any other like Compass it's
like any other chest screwed in that
I hate the map
foreign
yeah it's just the one it's just yeah
it's all it's just the boss key and just
we have to go all the way we've like
trudged all the way back there just to
uh get that one chest when we get
inspired
yeah
uh
which place can oh yeah the spirit
Temple uh
what is that yeah that's that's the plan
for next time the spare time what is the
fastest route to that place
not the mini way I think yeah at the
menu probably
uh oh I forgot that we have this Forest
warp song I just walked all the way here
for no reason
well the water tempo is not that bad but
if you at least not the vanilla version
It's
it's not hard
it's just confusing the first time
because you don't know what the heck is
going on
[Applause]
anywhere 12.
there it was okay okay actually well at
least I was 12. oh I got it hello I'm
not sure why I didn't go here before
how have I not been here
like seriously
[Music]
cool guys don't look at explosions
[Applause]
oh no
what was it before stopping again did
you see that no that marbling went crazy
and it just ran right past me I thought
it was gonna scoop me off the ladder and
take me with him but apparently he
cannot hit you when you're like almost
at the top of the ladder well you should
probably just kill him because he filled
his job again it's probably gonna kill
him anyway yeah let's let's just let's
just like put him out of his misery
bomb
bomb do what you wanted
oh no no I mean you kind of you kind of
deserve that one I'd be perfectly honest
no I blame the controls what was in the
force Temple actually
foreign
[Music]
I have no idea why were you there anyway
oh wait because you came out of the
force now I'm on my way to the spirit
Temple no no no no no no no no no no no
no
but why were you with uh oh because it's
I mean it's so impatient when it comes
to these guys dude I don't think we ever
went in here
I don't think we went in we had to meet
you at the forest last time I I did go
in in there really one time at least
[Music]
nothing in here forget forget it existed
yeah
how did I not go be here as a kid though
like sorry I had the summer storms the
whole time
Syria yeah and I just apparently never
went here I have no idea why
[Music]
makes my life a lot easier then I know
you can use the hook shutter but I'm
just I like bombing everyone
thank you
I'll see you uh k020
thanks for dropping by
e
he also went by you're uh
viewership is always greatly appreciated
I feel like I don't thank people enough
I shouldn't do it more often
just for being taking time out of your
schedule to watch me screw around at
playing terribly
you you think you'd be able to see this
like
what you you think you'd be able to see
a guy just standing bagging on the like
no I mean it's like uh dogs they cannot
look up I guess maybe they just smell
you actually dogs can't look up
I've never heard of a dog who can't look
up oh that's from shot of the Dead oh
have you never seen that movie oh we
gotta watch shot of the Dead sometime
it's a British uh British British zombie
movie or zombie comedy movie actually
and uh
like during the whole uh movie there's
like two or three times where they just
keep getting into a discussion about
dogs being able to look up yes or no
what kind of discussion is that
[Music]
it's like random discussion they can't
look up no they can't of course they
can't
[Music]
nothing I care about who do you have
nothing I care about okay bye oh awesome
Steward yeah Fridays are much more fun
when Jesse is run it's just that we
sometimes we just have live stuff in the
way yeah or I'm working on a video
because my last video I would not have
been able to finish that one if I didn't
cancel our stream for that Friday
because I barely made it before
Christmas I was like this video has to
go up before Christmas because if I
upload it on Christmas Nova nobody's
gonna watch it
it's gonna get a terrible first day and
then the algorithm will be like nobody
likes your stuff and then it just gets
buried and it just leads to death buried
by the algorithm buried by the algorithm
this video Never Happened folks
I'm pretty sure that YouTube's algorithm
is like a mind of its own right yeah I'm
pretty sure even the it's unexplainable
how it works because I've also had
videos that were performing terribly and
then suddenly they pick up like a few
days later they suddenly gets crazy
views and I'm like why what did I do
differently I'm not sure if like if this
is true or not but I thought I read
somewhere that like even the YouTube
employees have no idea how their own
algorithm works at this point no it's
Skynet it's basically just Skynet we've
created an artificial intelligence and
it's gonna kill us all in nuclear fire
I mean the fact that they created
something that pretty much has a will of
its owner at this point
it's pretty impressive stuff
yeah
it's a bit of a bit scary that it
determines my salary yeah
yeah I mean
be honest if uh artificial intelligence
starts uh running wild I'm pretty sure
you have bigger things to worry about
well if we get destroyed by artificial
intelligence then we deserve it because
how hard it can it be to at least design
an off button
oh you [ __ ] oh oh actually I changed my
mind remember Weck went in the Ice
Cavern when I said that the thing was my
least favorite room look how many
I forgot that this was my least favorite
room in the game
I think the normal version of the spirit
Temple you can just long shot through
the ceiling
and there was no purpose in this room
did you know about that what in the
normal version where you don't have to
collect did you see that snipe I'm very
proud of you in the normal version of
the the oh another one yeah and you know
you can just you can you can just long
shot to this to the top in the normal
version and then yeah they're out of
there but you need to get the silver
rupees in this one
foreign
oh I guess you can just
shut them you cannot do it on the moving
ones I think the ones that move don't
accept your hook shot
which is weird look
it doesn't accept it like nope
this is weird
I'm a moving platform ain't nobody gonna
get a hook shot on to me
come on
no
oh never mind
or else you will die
die
you dare bring a light to my Lair you
must you must die
why is he so biased towards link he's
like oh yeah you should join me link and
then with sound it's just like darn
yeah he doesn't care much for Zelda does
he
[Music]
captain bergerson that uh that video
that you posted on Twitter where you uh
get the koroxy that was pretty damn
genius I had no idea you could do it
like that in fact I don't even remember
how I got it
or if I even did I did the car there's
like a car accident wild in lurlin
Village it's like on one of the rooftops
of the those little boat houses I
believe you and I don't know like
there's like a ring of rocks there you
have to do the usual thing take a rock
from somewhere and they're just you know
but of course when you're carrying a
rock in in breath of the wild you cannot
paraglide you cannot do anything yeah so
how are you are you supposed to get that
rock up there except I don't know launch
it with stasis or
like I'm sure there's different ways to
do it with the other chica runes but he
he chopped down a tree which would then
fall towards the house then he freeze it
with stasis and then grabs the Rock and
walks across the tree uh that works is
actually a very good it's actually very
because if you don't freeze it is if you
don't freeze it the tree will just roll
off kind of
um
it's those types of things and that make
me love the uh the physics engine of
rest of the wildco oh yeah that's just
like even even in shrines they're like
non-intended methods of completing
certain things yeah just by being smart
and just thinking about like Creative
Solutions
actually it's uh you're gonna miss your
training that's about that's about time
you're gonna miss your trade I will just
uh open this door
go in
and do nothing
because this guy's in my way you know
you can beat him and then we'll uh then
we'll call it a couple of the day yeah
I want to go to one more cave anyway
[Music]
is there any significance to the fact
that this guy
why does he have free throws
what oh actually yeah it's like sick no
he's like nine Thrones why why does he
need nine Thrones
let's see if I can throw a bomb in here
ball
you should have killed him with moms
actually now to think about it
yeah I should
come on
[Music]
yeah
Bob's good ball
I know there's cave in here don't do it
with me I think it's just skill to us
it seems like I should have let him
destroy this
mom I know it's here
so we're way too hook shot hook shot my
way in there
[Music]
that works too
[Music]
but now I'm stuck what's with all the
fairy fish like the third fairy fountain
that I found now I'm stuck inside this
dude all the Song of Storms caves just
lead to fairy fountains for some reason
oh like all of them I know there's never
been a single one that's been useful
pretty upsetting actually I'm stuck
I guess I can go into the bottle of the
well next time
I'll just save the game this is just
skill to us and I will continue in this
dungeon hopefully we can uh play again
next week I'm probably free
I'm also probably free but let's not
promise anything yeah that's why I'm
probably we will maybe see you again uh
either in two months or next week so
actually let me shut that off the music
let me save the game
sorry uh we have to leave guys or else
uh Jesse here is gonna miss his train
home yeah unfortunately so
or else we would have easily been able
to do this for another two hours but
all all good things come to an end
sometime
I mean thank you all so so much for
showing up as always and I will see you
guys in the next video and in which is
not this weekend next weekend and the
next stream which is also next week yeah
so yeah thanks for showing up
and uh
we shall talk soon see you next time
we did the marker player bye bye
-bye bye-bye